BRIAN: UNBELIEVABLE WELL PUT
PETER THANKS SO MUCH.
MEANWHILE LET’S BRING IN FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR RETIRED ACTING
I.C.E. DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN DO YOU
BLAME TRUMP FOR THE PROBLEMS AT
THE BORDER?
>> I DON’T.
LET ME ADDRESS THIS STATEMENT
MADE BY SECRETARY THAT THERE’S
NOT A CRISIS.
THAT THAT IS DISTURBING BECAUSE
WHEN HE WAS DEPUTY SECRETARY IN
2015 AND JEH JOHNSON WAS
SECRETARY I MET WITH THEM
NUMEROUS TIMES WEEK TO TALK
ABOUT THE BORDER CROSSINGS HOW
MANY ARE CROSSING AND DETAIN AND
ORDERED TO MOVE AND THRESHOLD WE
SENT AT THE TILE WAS A THOUSAND
CROSS ATION DAY WAS THE BAD DAY
IT WAS A CRISIS AND NOW WE’RE
DOING WHAT 4,000 A DAY 4 TIMES
WHAT CONSIDERED A CRISIS BACK IN
2015 HE’S NOT BEING TRUTH TO
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THERE ARE CERTAINLY A CRISIS ON
BORDER THAT IS MANUFACTURING AND
WHICH CREATED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE THEIR
PROMISES THAT THEY MADE IN TO
THE PEOPLE.
>> 4 THUNDER SHOWER UNACCOMPANY
MINORS NOW IN OUR COUNTRY,
THAT’S A 19% INCREASE YEAR TO
YEAR.
THEY HAVE ELIMINATED WAR
BUILDINGS STOPPED REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY WHERE 71,000 I
GUESS CENTRAL AND SOUTH
AMERICANS SITTING THERE WAITING
I GUESS THEY END UP HERE TO PUSH
LEGALIZING DREAMERS AND BRINGING
BACK IN DEPORTED ILLEGAL WHICH
IS IS STUNNING ALONG WITH A
HUNDRED DAY PAUSE ON
DEPORTATIONS THAT --
EXCUSE ME THAT TEXAS WITH THE
COURT TO POLL, OF COURSE, IT IS
A CRISIS THEY’RE ACTUALLY
SCRIPTED THIS CRISIS.
>> BY DESIGN WHEN YOU MAKE THOSE
TYPE OF PROMISES ON TOP OF THAT
BRIAN GIVE YOU FREE HEALTH CARE,
WHEN YOU MAKE TYPE OF PROMISES
THEY’RE GOING TO COME AND THEY
KNEW WHEN THEY SAID THESE THINGS
IT WAS GOAPG TO CAUSE BORDER
CRISIS THEY FORWARD TO
PROGRESSIVE LEFT AND IT IS
INCREDIBLE WHAT HE MADE A
STATEMENT YESTERDAY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP GUTTED SYSTEM
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
HE AS A SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY MORE IMMIGRATION JUDGES
HE HAS MORE AGENTS.
HE HAS MORE BORDER TECHNOLOGY,
HE HAD AGREEMENTS THAT NO OTHER
PRESIDENT ABLE TO GET IF ANYBODY
IS GUTTED THE SYSTEM IT IS
THEY’VE GUTTED IS LAST FOUR
WEEKS AND WE SEE WHAT HAPPENED
WE WENT FROM HISTORIC LOWS TO A
CRISIS UNPRECEDENTED THAT IS
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE.
>> NOT A LACK OF COMPASSION THE
MESSAGE WE SENDING HERE FORCES
THESE TRIANGLE COUNTRIES TO SEND
PEOPLE AND HOPE ON PROMISE
THAT’LL GET THROUGH INSTEAD OF
GOING THROUGH SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS
PERHAPS MORE REFUGEES IN AND
REVAMP TO IMMIGRATION REFORM.
BUT TOIPGHT BRING YOU TO TWO
MORE TOP PIX BEFORE I HAVE TO
LET YOU GO DHS SECRETARY SAID
YESTERDAY THAT LOVING PARENTS
SENDING THEIR KIDS ALONE
THOUSANDS OF MILE THROUGH
CENTRAL AMERICA THROUGH VEHICLE
AND WE’RE NOT EXPELLING THEM AND
NOT A HENGD THROUGH MEXICO WHOSE
LOVING PARENTS SENT THEM HERE
ALONE.
WELL IF WE DON’T SENDING THEM
BACK TENS OF THOUSANDS WILL COME
AFTER THEM.
WE CANNOT DIGEST --
ENTIRE COUNTRY CAN WE?
NO BUT CAN’T AND INHUMANE TO PUT
YOUR HANDS IN CARTEL AND DON’T
CARE ABOUT DIAGNOSE CHILDREN
I’VE HELD MANY DYING CHILDREN I
WAS BACK IN TRACTOR TRAILER WITH
FIVE-YEAR-OLD BOY SUFFOCATED TO
DEATH DON’T TELL ME THIS IS
COMPASSION.
PUTTING YOUR CHILDREN IN A
HANDLE OF CRIMINAL CARTELS IS
INHUMANE AND DANGEROUS AND BAD
AND I’VE SEEN IT AND I JUST
CAN’T BELIEVE THAT STATEMENT WAS
EVEN MADE.
>> IT WAS KRISTIN FISHER ASKED
THIS QUESTION YESTERDAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING.
THE PRESIDENT OF MEXICO IS GOING
TO PROPOSE AN IDEA TO BRING AN
IMMIGRANT LABOR FORCE OF 600 TO
800,000 GRANTS A YEAR TO WORK
LEGALLY IN THE UNITED STATES.
IS THAT SOMETHING WE SHOULD
CONSIDER THE ANSWER FROM JEN
PSAKI I’VE SEEN THOSE REPORTS I
BELIEVE THAT STEP THAT WILL
REQUIRE CONGRESS SHOULD CONGRESS
GREEN LIGHT THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO SECURE OUR
BORDER AND ENFORCE LAWS THAT
THEY WROTE AND ENACTED THAT WAS
SIGNED BY PRESIDENT.
LOOK, LAST YEAR MEXICO RECEIVED
40 BILLION DOLLARS AND FROM
PEOPLE HERE WORKING IN THE
UNITED STATES E LAW LAW ILLEGALL
BILLION IN A YEAR OF PANDEMIC
AND MORE PEOPLE HERE BECAUSE YOU
DON’T HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THEM
AND PROVIDE SOCIAL SERVICES OR
TRAIN THEM SEND US BACK MORE
THAN 40 BILLION DOLLARS THIS IS
A WIN/WIN FOR MEXICO BAD FOR THE
UNITED STATES BAD FOR AMERICAN
WORKER.
>> TOM WHAT DID THEY SAY JOBS
AMERICANS DON’T WANT TO WORK
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> THAT IS UNTRUE.
THAT’S UNTRUE I’VE DONE MANY
INVESTIGATIONS WORK SIDE
OPERATION WHERE IS WE HIT --
WE’VE HIT WORK SITE WHERE THESE
JOBS ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS NOW
SOME ARE GOOD PAYING JOBS DON’T
GET ME WRONG BUT A LOT OF JOBS
THAT MIDDLE CLASS AMERICANS
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE RIGHT NOW
DURING THIS TIME OF
UNEMPLOYMENT.
>> PLUS, I MEAN WE’LL GET IN
TROUBLE GETTING OFF ON AIRPLANE
WE HAVE A REPORT IN
QUARANTINE --
WE’RE LETTING THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN WHO AREN’T SOCIALLY
DISTANCE AND DON’T TRAVEL WITH
RAPID TEST.
IT IS JUST --
NOT LOGICAL IT IS NOT --